damit ihr habt mit leider gestrickt vom
schneider doch die blicke und ja da geht
es natürlich darum dass viel
materialismus im spiel ist und das wird
immer alles reduziert auf ein schickes
gepflegtes äußeres auftreten und das hat
aber nichts damit zu tun dass man dicke
eier also durchsetzungsvermögen auch hat
wenn man viel geld hat oder schicke
kleider geschneidert
leider treffen uns denn wir haben dicke
eier und du hast schöne dinge an aber
deine argumente ich bin ich war oft ein
rohling gebrannt alles klar also sagt
eigentlich genau das gleiche aus schicke
ohrringe viel geld aber trotzdem ist die
musik scheiße was soll man machen
rohling gebrannt wie geht's weiter ab
obwohl die gala apropos dicke eier jetzt
gibt's teebeuteln jeder weiß was jeder
weiß was die bergen ist die frau kniet
unter einem und man lässt das gehänge in
ihrem mund ein bisschen hin und her
baumeln wie eine schiffschaukel oder so
und statt der frau ist es in dem fall
deutschrap könnte man sagen und wir
stehen drüber und lassen unsere dicken
eier quasi in den mund von deutschrap
rein baumeln so ja wenn man es auf den
deutsch map insgesamt bezieht es ja
nicht unbedingt schwul
jetzt gibts die beuteln eure frauen
tauchen ab wie seeteufel wir sind mehr
als zehn leute alle sind killers gegen
uns wirken du und deine kubi chinchillas
soll heißen dass wir so gut gebaut und
breit gebaut auf sind das die ganzen
anderen so klein und haarig lustig
aussehen wie diese chinchilla tiefe
nächste zeile oder ich war da gibt's ja
nicht viel zu erklären das ist ja so
eindeutig präzise extra geschrieben dass
es jeder verstehen kann
hört auf zu zehn geht auf der kirmes
unten schießen andere router zuckerwatte
bratäpfel dass männer links bands wie
was geht das sagt er dann und ich sag
deutsche bäcker sind arm es geht darum
dass man dinge auch auf zählt die
deutsche rapper liebe machen sollten als
zu werben weil sie zu wenig talent
bewiesen haben wie zum beispiel auf die
kirmes gehen und damit assoziiere ich
zum beispiel schmetterlings bahn
bratäpfel autoscooter diese ganzen
sachen die super viel spaß machen aber
für mich nichts mit geld zu tun haben
deswegen sollten diese rapper die nicht
retten können lieber das machen als zu
retten
wie das geht das bin ich über konkrete
deutsche rapper sind arm aber sie tun so
als wären sie reich und machen auf dicke
hose und deswegen haben sie keine dicken
außer euch etwas zu zeigen dass auch
schöner ist als kaka noch schöner als
der klang von krefeld
ich finde für mich gehört zu den
schönsten gefühlen die ich haben kann
persönlich kacken zu gehen wenn ich auf
klose zu dann vergesse ich alles das es
so romantisch und ich kriege eine
gänsehaut jedes mal wenn die wurst
machen harsch fall ist und deswegen
vergleiche ich einfach unsere platte mit
dem gefühl packen zu gehen nicht nur
weil wir auf alles schießen und unser
ding einfach machen sondern einfach
gefühlsmäßig stelle ich das auf eine
ebene weil es für mich kaum was
schöneres gibt als zu scheißen richtig
schön
es kommt so noch der zweite part machen
wir eigentlich jeder eine stufe oder der
genau jetzt noch mal zusammen es sind
weiß die onkelz i2s bomben bis 1934
du hast das album gar nicht gehört doch
aber ich denke die comics nicht nur ein
krasses teil der schreien was für ein
scheiß wir beide hautnah wieder
lautstark ist ja nicht wir uns für die
zuschauer zu
wollte ich nicht kommt immer noch wann
das ein oder andere haftbefehl hatte ich
zum das stimmt ihr seid alle passt alles
deutschen ja englisch und thai soll
genau dann kommt der nächste lassen ein
anderes lied machen das gleiche lied
meine sonne drei minuten
die leute wahnsinnig dankbar solchen
drüber schreiben die trendanalyse dann
kommen lauter titel nein gemeint sagt er
den ausgangspunkt weshalb das gemacht
haben erklärt sich das von sehen ob wir
kürzen das ganze abbekommen 2000
zentrale frage die wir uns gestellt
haben war welche single werden wir
auskoppeln und dann war die nächste
frage betteln oder total soft und ich
war der meinung battle ja aber so ein
bisschen ironisch betteln weil erstens
maße ich mir nicht an besser betteln zu
können als die assis von der straße
sprich haftbefehl und azzlack und was
weiß ich
das können wir gut nicht in einer
abfahrt habe ich gesagt habe und
zweitens ist das auch nicht unser job
unser unser metier uns da hinzustellen
und zu sagen wir sind besser als ihr
alles sein sondern wir wollten einfach
nur sagen dass wie ihr seid ist ein
bisschen lächerlich und das wie andere
leute das finden wenn ihr so seit hat
sehr viel damit zu tun wie sie gerne
wären wenn sie so sein könnten wie ihr
es nicht sein und das ist so da muss man
halt das was ist ebenfalls register
selbst befruchtung vieles ist da so auch
selbstbefriedigung sowie hohe nutzen auf
uns runter aber eigentlich sind wir das
gar nicht diese leute die mit der
pumpgun in der hand da rumstehen und die
großen auf dicke hose machen die sind
total bürgerlich die wohnen im
einfamilienhaus die haben drei autos vor
der tür stehen und schicken ihre kinder
in die kita und essen müsst die von
alnatura und dann wenn sie ihren job
machen so wie bushido jetzt auch dann
fangen sie wieder an leuten den kopf zu
schießen oder in asch zu [ __ ] das war
ja gerade das ding bei bushido dass
diejenigen die
den integrationspreis verliehen haben
vergessen haben was der eigentlich
beruflich macht
texter rapper und integrations rapper er
dann wirklich so ausländer
ob die deutschen lieben ich denke dichte
da stuttgart
und wenn der innenminister den damals
sichert ablichten lassen mit ihm das da
gewusst hätte und ich glaube er wusste
dass er hätte es wissen müssen dann
hätte jeder gesagt seid bloß vorsichtig
das kann auf dich zurück kommen ja aber
das muss man muss da unterscheiden
zwischen dem künstler der rolle spielte
ward menschen die privat gegen künstler
ich sage nur dass dieses ganze image was
da aufgebaut wird durchschaubar ist und
das ist absolut okay ist wenn man das
als kunstform betrachtet dann sagst du
achtest lustig die machen das ist eher
ein genre einen auf dicke hose zu machen
und das aber auch irgendwie so zu lassen
aber die glauben ja selbst dann das was
die machen als ich glaube viele glauben
selbst sehr an das was sie machen und
ich glaube die bilden sich sogar
manchmal ein dass die sonne total
verkorkste vergangenheit haben und erst
wenn diese ihren gymnasiallehrer treffer
was machst du die scheiße öffentlichkeit
was über eine eins in mathe gehabt das
sehe ich ob leute kinder
das war die analyse das war der grund
weshalb wir gesagt haben dicke eier auf
einer ironischen ebene durchschaubar
dass wir uns sozusagen über die stellen
und sagen irgendwie kann das jeder das
keine große kunst die fresse aufzumachen
viel interessanter ist dann da zu sein
wenn eine große fresse gebraucht wird
und dafür muss sich manche dieser leute
ich vermisse battle rap wenn es um
gerechtigkeit geht ich vermisse battle
rapper und gangster das fenster umgeht
schwächere in schutz zu nehmen wenn es
darum geht tolerant gegenüber
minderheiten zu sein gegenüber schwulen
oder leuten die hier keine rechte
besitzen
die sollen an erster front stehen wenn
asylanten unrecht getan wird wenn es
politisch ist auch mal die klappe
aufreißen und nicht nur in ihrem
mikrokosmos dahinschweben macht den
kiwis in milch do isch halt so oft hin
ich halt so aufgehen wie ein stricher ja
ich bin jeden abend auf der bühne und
lass mich von den vorbehalten der
zuschauern pumpen
ich bin jeden moment da wo ich gebraucht
werde und lass mich von den vorurteilen
der leute die nur ein klischee
wahrnehmen in frage stellen und versucht
sie zu überzeugen dass es nicht so ist
und das ist meine erste bürgerpflicht
genauso wie es bürgerpflicht ist all
dieser künstler denn kunst hat auch
immer ein aufklärerischen aspekt der
manchmal vernachlässigt wird wenn es zu
viel selbst beweisen wird es gibt ich
habe das jetzt gelernt und bitte
christoph also ich bin sehr vorsichtig
weil wenn ich alle rapper kennen würde
würde ich mir immer noch kein urteil
über alle erlauben
manche entpuppen sich zum beispiel als
unglaublich vielschichtig viel
vielschichtiger als ich vorher gedacht
habe weil ich nur fünf sekunden des
tracks gehört habe denselben fehler
gemacht habe wie den den ich den anderen
gerade vorgeworfen habe aber es gibt
auch vollidioten azzlack spaß dies
mangos die immer dieselbe masche reiten
wo ich sage kommt für zu auf wiedersehen
muss ich nicht zum zwanzigsten mal hören
manchmal ist aber auch witzig also ich
muß gegeben
du wolltest ja so eine art imaginären
battle zwischen mir und haftbefehl
inszeniert haftbefehl ist alles schon
der kann was ja absolut kann was
definitiv und wenn er auch nur einen auf
dicke hose machen kann
aber dass man einander gut besser als
medlock danke